Wilson: Okay, so I think we're
gonna go ahead and get going.
People are still sort of
filtering in from lunch,
but that's cool.
So welcome. Good afternoon.
I hope you all had a good lunch.
Um, I'm Chris Wilson.
This is my colleague Dan Lee,
and we're here to talk with you
about building Web Apps
for Google TV.
And, um, if you want to tweet
about this--this presentation,
this session, our, um, hash tag
is on every slide,
so handy reference.
You don't need to remember it
up front. It's #gtvweb.
I'm gonna resist the temptation
to actually watch Twitter
while I'm talking,
but, um, you can queue up
questions for the end.
So before we really get going,
I want to cover why television
is even interesting,
like, why we should care
about television.
It's kind of old media.
Probably a lot of you
in this room, um,
may not even have a TV.
I know a number of friends
who don't have a TV anymore.
But, you know,
we do have the Web.
But the interesting fact
is that TV is actually
really, really popular.
Um, more American households
have TVs than cell phones
or computers.
Computers--they're about--
80% of American households
have computers,
and, uh, about 90% of American
households have cell phones,
some form of mobile device,
and 99% of American households
have at least 1 TV.
In fact, more than,
uh, more than half
of those households
have three or more TVs.
That's a whole lot
of surface area
and a whole lot of, uh,
a whole lot of screens
for applications to be on.
Worldwide, of course, numbers
are a little bit different,
but worldwide three-quarters
of all households
have TVs in them.
So even, you know, third world
nations and everything,
three-quarters of everyone
has a TV in their home.
In addition to that,
you know, that's kind of
all TVs, right?
That's every kind of old
NTSC TV, PAL TV, whatever.
What we're really talking
about here, of course,
is internet-capable
or "smart" TVs.
And there are not,
relatively speaking,
tons of these out there today.
There are about 2 million in
the U.S., um, as of last year.
But by 2014, it's expected
that more than a third
of all U.S. households
will have
an internet-connected TV in it,
uh, 43 million.
So you can see
the growth curve on this
has to be pretty astronomical
to get up that high.
In addition to that,
TV is actually used
more than any other media.
Um, in fact, in today,
uh, Americans spend more time
watching TV
than computer use and listening
to music put together.
And this is among
8 to 18 year olds, right?
This is among young kids,
teenagers,
the ones you would expect would
actually not be so focused on TV
and would be more focused
on listening to music
or using the computer to chat
with their friends or whatever.
They're actually
still watching TV
more than both of those
put together.
In fact, they--they watch TV
more than three times as much
as they use a computer.
So to sum up,
TVs are more common
than computers.
Americans actually spend
more time watching TV
than any other activity,
so we kind of ought to make
better use of this time.
Now that sounds like I'm saying
"stop watching TV."
Um, that's not
actually my point, obviously.
What I'm really saying is
there's a lot of opportunities
to make that
TV experience better,
and that's really what
we want to talk about today,
and that's really what sparked
the Google TV project, in fact.
The ideas behind Google TV
were really pretty simple.
First of all,
we can take live TV,
the regular TV experience,
and make it a lot better.
We can apply search to it,
since obviously, Google knows
a little bit about search.
We can give live info
on what's on,
so that we can help you find
stuff that you want to watch
rather than you having to sit
there with your cable remote
flipping through 500 channels,
hoping to find
something interesting.
Secondly, there's a lot
of great Web content
out there already on the Web,
and it's kind of silly
to watch all of these videos
and--and other content
in a little 6-inch window
on your 13-inch laptop
when you've got the biggest
screen in the house
probably staring at you
in your living room,
and you probably have
the best sound system in your
house attached to it, as well.
Statistically speaking,
that's usually true.
You have the best speaker system
attached to your TV system.
Now there are 2 billion videos
watched every day
on YouTube alone.
Um, there are 35 hours of video
uploaded to YouTube
every minute.
So this actually outstrips
what you can watch live
by about 2,100 times.
So, um, they can't all
be funny cat videos.
There should be enough
to keep you busy.
So there's tons
of great Web content.
We want to get that on TV.
And the final idea
behind Google TV,
and this is really what
we're here to talk about,
is smart TV obviously
needs a platform
for interactive applications.
Manufacturers
were already starting
to kind of roll their own
vertical platforms for smart TV.
And we kind of said,
"Hey, we already have
a platform.
"We have two platforms,
actually,
Android and the Web Platform."
Both of those
make a great platform
for interactive TV apps.
With an interactive platform,
when you start thinking
about all the time
that you spend
parked in front of your TV,
there are some
really specific opportunities
that come to mind,
and we want to--to mention
a few of these particular areas,
that we're compelling, up front.
First, any
media consumption activity
that might have a social aspect
can be really compelling on TV.
So if you want to watch the game
together with your friends,
but you don't actually want them
in your living room
eating your nachos,
drinking your beer,
um, you can do that if you have
an interactive platform
that can consume media
and connect to the internet
at the same time.
There's also a big opportunity
for applications
that span across devices
or environments.
The example
that I usually use here
is you can build an application
centered around food.
And you can sit on your couch
and watch episodes
of your favorite cooking show.
And then when you see something
that looks really tasty,
you want to make it for dinner,
you head to the store,
and pull out your mobile device,
and the application now running
on your mobile device
already knows what
you were looking at,
and it gives you
a shopping list.
In fact, it might even guide you
based on your location
to what stores you need to go to
to get the right ingredients.
And then finally, you go back
to your kitchen.
You go to make the recipe.
And with your laptop
or your tablet
or another TV bolted
to your wall or whatever,
you get the actual recipe steps
and maybe videos on how
to properly caramelize onions
or something like that.
Next, casual games are another
really interesting area for TV.
I say "casual games,"
and I mention games here
because obviously, games on TV
have a very long history.
Yes, I had an Atari 2600
at one point.
Um, I don't say games
across the board here
because I think that
casual games are an opportunity.
They really haven't been
nailed on TV yet.
Console games actually
very, very healthy--
uh, healthy ecosystem right now.
It's more--I think
there's a lot of opportunity
to build more casual games
and get them on the TV space
when you sit down,
and you want to kill a few--
few minutes playing something.
Which brings me
to the last opportunity
and this is the opportunity
to make connected applications
that pair
or work across devices,
and this is really
because I don't think I've
actually sat down to watch TV
any time in the last three
or four years
without having my mobile device
or a tablet
on me at the same time.
Like, I'll check IMDb
or something like that.
And we have built a Google TV
remote control application
for iOS and Android
so you can effectively replace
your remote control
with your mobile device.
So you pull it out.
You can flip channels,
change the volume, whatever,
do searches,
drive the pointer device.
But that's not really the key
thing that I'm getting at here.
What we really want people
to focus on
is building applications
that connect mobile devices
and tablets
or any other device together
to drive the experience
on the big screen.
You already have in your hand
or your purse
or, uh, or your pocket,
um, a device that has
a ton of controllers on it,
a ton of sensors.
You know, you have audio input.
You have an accelerometer
and a gyroscope,
audio--
and a touch screen display.
You, um--we want
to connect that to the TV.
We shouldn't need to give you
yet another remote control
to lose.
You're already carrying one.
So I think we want to give
a very quick demo
of a couple of applications
that show this sort of thing.
And the first one
is...
Interesting, it seems
to have lost me.
man: Hey, I don't have all day
here, people. Let's play.
Wilson: [laughs]
Well, let's see.
So we're both trying
to join this.
I'm--I'm joining it
from an iPhone.
man: You need at least
two people to play "WeDraw."
Wilson: Dan is trying
to join it from...
Okay, why don't you know, uh...
Lee: You want to start?
Wilson: My iOS device
is actually unconnecting.
man: Everybody ready?
Let's do this.
Wilson: Okay. Connecting.
Hey, there we go.
man: Round 1, start.
Wilson: So this application,
um--
one of us, and I'm not sure
who it is yet, gets to draw...
man: Player 1, get
those fingers ready.
Wilson: And this is
essentially like "Pictionary."
Alan Queen, right on,
from the audience, even.
So Alan gets a word
on his mobile device,
and it says
you should draw something.
And I'm gonna guess
that looks like a... snake.
Oh.
man: And player 4 makes
short work of the competition.
Wilson: All right!
Andre guessed "river,"
but I--I beat him to it.
So you can see all of us
are participating in this--
in this experience right now
from our own personal devices.
There are lots of other ideas
for applications
that you may want to, um, to
implement that work like this.
Uh, this is, uh,
a MOVL application.
They're actually
in the Sandbox today,
so they're showing off
some of their
other applications, as well.
Let me go ahead and close that.
Lee: [laughs]
Wilson: There are a lot of other
applications that really--
that don't yet make use of...
[bang]
Wilson: the sort of
paired controller idea,
but, um... [laughs]
but give you a lot of--
it's kind of a social aspect
in the living room,
and one of those that we want
to just show really quickly
was another HTML-based demo
called the KARAOKE Channel.
And Dan's gonna sing
for you here.
Lee: All right.
Wilson: I personally think
we should open up to a vote
as to what he sings,
but, um, I think
he had a-a request.
Um...
Oh, wait, there it was.
So this is actually
a relatively simple application,
um, but it's very compelling
on your big screen.
I'm gonna go ahead
and pop it full screen
so you get a more
TV-like experience.
Lee singing: Now I had
the time of my life.
No, I never
felt this way before.
Yes, I swear.
It's the truth.
And I--
[normal voice] Oh.
Wilson: [laughs]
[laughter]
Wilson: They're all
saying "mic," Dan.
[cheers and applause]
Wilson: So really, the key point
we're trying to get here
is that there are some
very engaging applications,
and having it on a big screen--
and obviously this might be
a little bit bigger
than your TV--
is a really good idea.
It's--it's a really good way
to engage multiple people.
Now as I mentioned before,
Google TV and Android--
Google TV is based on Android.
It's--it's an Android device.
And we will be unlocking
the ability to, uh,
for consumers to install
Android applications very soon.
Christian and Jason
have a session about that side,
um, actually the next session
round this afternoon,
uh, up in building 11.
Er, building 11--room 11.
But here, we're talking
about the Web platform.
Now Google TV's Web platform
is Chrome.
It has a special TV UI
applied to it
so you get, uh, an address bar
that doesn't always sit there
and take up space,
and you have
a very TV-centric design
to be driven
from a directional pad
navigation system.
But this means we have
a modern browser.
We have HTML5.
We have--we're built
on top of WebKit.
We also have Adobe Flash
implemented on Google TV.
We have H.264 video
natively implemented, as well,
so any--any content
that needs that
is--is gonna be there on TV.
And finally, I want to mention
we update automatically
over the network.
So the Web platform
gets better over time.
You don't have to do anything.
Um, mine at home has updated
multiple times already, so...
Now I basically just said
we support the Web platform.
If you're already
a Web developer,
I kind of said the magic words.
I said "WebKit"
and "Web platform."
So what more
do you need to know?
Like, you can all leave.
Um, we're only 15 minutes in
or something.
But it turns out
TV is a little bit
of a different space.
It's a different mental space.
Users tend to be
in what we sometimes call
"couch mode"
or "lean back" mode.
They're in this very passive
interaction mode.
They don't really want
to lean forward and, uh,
sit there with a keyboard
and a mouse and drive it.
In fact, I was sitting there
watching TV with my wife,
and a commercial for interactive
TV came on one time,
and my wife actually said,
"But I don't want
to be interactive.
I just want to watch TV."
And I tried to explain
what I did again,
and she kind of got
a little confused.
[laughter]
Wilson: But the idea is,
well, you really need to--
to build a UI,
to build an application,
that is in that kind of space,
right,
that you provide a UI that
you're comfortable driving
kicking back on your couch
from 10 feet away.
[music playing]
[laughter]
Wilson: So I want to give--
wow, that's a weird--
so I want to give
a couple of examples
of Web sites that have already
gone and done this work,
that have built a,
um, a 10-foot UI
of some--some form or another
and call out a few things
about 'em.
So this is Vimeo.
Um, I'm actually using Vimeo
as an example here
because I use YouTube later,
So, um, Vimeo is
a video content Web site,
and this is what I get.
I'm already logged in as me.
Whoops.
This is what I get
if I don't lock my screen.
Um, it's got
a ton of stuff on it,
and the text is really small,
and it's hard for me to read,
and it's hard for me
to actually find
what it is that I'm--
I want to watch.
Like, maybe I want
to hear some more
about my camera or something.
But it's not really, um--you
know, I have to navigate this.
You also notice there's
a big scroll bar on the side.
There's actually a couple pages'
worth of--of content
just on this page alone.
And I'm not even sure
what the statistics thing
is on this page.
Now Vimeo also has
what they call Couch Mode,
and Couch Mode
is a little different
because Couch Mode--
when you go to Couch Mode,
this is what you get.
The video starts
playing immediately,
and you can still navigate
through all the content.
You can find different things
to--to watch.
But this feels like TV, right?
You turn it on, and it just
starts playing content.
It's not like you have
to go discover and lean in
and figure out
what you want to do next.
It is kind of
a passive experience.
Similar to that--
this is "The Huffington Post"
news, uh, news site.
And again, you'll notice
there's a scroll bar,
and this one's
really impressive
because this is many, many,
many, many, many,
many pages of content,
and down at the bottom,
you have a huge, like--
the news source's menu
is even bigger
than what will--will fit on
my screen at a readable size.
And "The Huffington Post"
built an application
called NewsGlide
that gives a different
kind of experience,
and it's still a news site,
and it's still kind of a static,
uh, static way
to look at the news,
but at the same time,
I can drive this
completely with the arrow keys
on my keyboard.
I don't need to use a--
I don't need to use a mouse
to navigate.
I--unfortunately because this is
running on the desktop browser,
I'm getting a scroll bar.
On TV, you don't,
and it resizes properly
so you get a much better
experience there.
Now the point
we're trying to get--
to get at
with both of these, um,
both of these quick demos
are--go ahead and flip--
are--
uh, there's different concepts
you need to keep in mind.
There's--there's different ideas
behind what you need to do
to design for TV,
and they fall
into three basic categories.
The first one
is technical constraints,
and these are things
like resolution TV runs at
and color issues
and things like that.
Then there are
practical constraints,
which is when you sit 10 feet
away, things look smaller--
big surprise--
and what kind of input
you typically have on your couch
and that sort of thing.
And then finally, we want
to cover a few things
that are design guidance,
and these are
a little bit more fuzzy.
They're more, um, well, this is
what makes a "TV experience."
And that doesn't mean
you can't--
you absolutely
can't violate these.
It's whatever you do,
the user is gonna find that
a little bit weird
or a little bit different,
I should say, from regular TV.
So on the first one of these,
on resolution--
and this feels really weird,
'cause I'm a longtime
Web platform guy,
and, you know, one of the hot
things to discuss right now,
um, in the Web design world
is the concept
of responsive design,
building flexible designs
that go across screen sizes
and window sizes.
TV has two resolutions
is the short version of this--
720p and 1080p--
and you can design
to those resolutions,
and that's okay.
Like, that's actually not
a bad thing to do at all.
It feels kind of weird,
but there you have it.
Except an old TV,
prior to HDTV, prior to
everyone having LCD flat panels,
um, there was this concept
called overscan.
And if you've never heard
of overscan before,
overscan is basically
on an old CRT-based display
the edges of the display
were kind of rounded off.
Um, some of the--the content
might get cut off
because of the rounded edges
of the display,
in the corners particularly,
because TVs typically
weren't exactly rectilinear.
And finally, the bezel
of the computer,
like, the plastic bit
around the tube itself,
could cut off
some of the content, too.
So they had rules
about where you were supposed
to put content
on one of these screens.
They had the "action safe" area
as basically the place where
you're supposed to display
anything that
the user doesn't really--
or the consumer needs to see.
So if you've got a character
in a video moving,
they probably want to stay
within that action safe space.
They might get cut off
on some displays occasionally,
but not a big deal.
If you're putting titles
or any textual information
or anything like that up,
you want to keep it
between 5% and 10%
away from the edges,
and this is a fairly sizable
chunk of--of screen real estate.
And it's why,
if you watch TV shows,
um, particularly older TV shows,
they don't put the titles
or the characters or anything
off at the corners ever.
That's why those little annoying
channel pop-ups,
they're not way off
in the corner.
They're actually, you know,
they kind of, uh,
intrude into your space.
And that's because they know
they might get
cut off otherwise.
Now technically, you would think
LCDs and plasma displays
wouldn't have
this problem, right?
You know exactly what resolution
you're designing for.
You should have every one
of those pixels
on your screen, right?
And I actually thought
this was true,
and then I went
and looked at the data,
and it turns out that only
about 40% of HDTVs sold today
have all their pixels,
like, actually are designed
for exactly 1080p or 720p.
Um, up to about 30% of them
drop 10% to 12% of their pixels,
like, literally
just don't have them.
So some displays
are still gonna be missing
the bits around the edge,
and you need to be careful
about having
a somewhat flexible display.
This means the edges of your
screen may still get cut off.
Don't build right to the edges
is the short version.
As well, you'll notice that, um,
this is essentially
the same design.
I just faked up one of them
a little bit.
You don't really want
to build to the edges
because on TV,
it makes your screen
look kind of, uh, unbalanced.
You really want to use
some extra padding space,
have some negative space
between things
because the user is sitting
quite a ways away.
They don't see things
that are rammed right up
next to each other very well.
Now briefly, I want
to talk about color.
Um, the short version
is the color gamut
is different on TV
than what you may be used to
on a computer.
NTSC gamut is still typically
used for TV displays,
and it's both somewhat limited
compared to sRGB
or--or, um, or the Adobe gamut.
Uh, but the real problem
is that TVs are frequently
not calibrated.
In fact, I would flip
that around and say
TVs are almost never
actually calibrated for color.
So the worst part of this
is that it's very easy
to oversaturate,
and in fact, people buy
their TVs for that.
Many TVs have a retail setting
that actually flips it
into oversaturating
and--and cranking up
the brightness
and contrast, as well.
Because when somebody goes in
to Best Buy to buy a new TV,
they typically look at all
the TVs that are out there,
and they pick the one
that's shiniest.
Um, unfortunately, this is not
the one that's most accurate
or best at representing colors.
It's just the one
that's shiniest.
So be careful about having
very saturated colors
in your Web designs,
any design that goes on TV.
Particularly oranges and reds
tend to kind of blow out
the, uh, blow out
the saturation pretty quickly.
Another interesting, uh,
interesting thing that
I didn't realize at first
and then it started making sense
is, um, white
is the default background
of the Web, right?
If you just put doctype HTML
and nothing else in a document
and load it up,
you get a white screen.
That's typically not what
you would expect on a TV.
On a TV, you would expect it
to be black.
If you go to a channel
that's not playing anything,
they're usually showing
a black screen,
or they're showing
a test pattern.
Now this actually ends up
translating to the consumer.
If you look at something
that is all white
or heavily white on a TV,
it feels like your TV
is screaming at you.
It's like all caps.
It's really, really
in-your-face,
and you don't generally
want that.
The other thing you have
to be careful about is, um,
if you use pure white
and pure black,
you will get halo effects
on some displays
because they're not
really designed
to do a very fast
transition back and forth
between opposite ends
of the spectrum.
This--I think
you can actually see it
on the--the screen up here.
Um, this is actually
a photo I took
of one of the TV screens
sitting at my desk,
and you can see, it's got
a weird little kind of
halo effect around each letter.
That's not a, you know, that's
not a shadow effect or anything.
That actually is just showing up
on the TV screen.
And in fact, the other TV
I have on my desk
doesn't have it at all.
So it's definitely TV-to-TV.
And that actually brings up
to the last point
of test your contrast
on an actual TV display,
not on a computer monitor
but on a TV.
And in fact, not just one TV,
it's best to test
on several different TVs
because you will get
different frequency responses
from them.
On practical constraints,
text is one of the areas
where, um--
you know, I can give you, like,
very definitive guidance
like don't ever use
6-point font,
um, but really the idea is
you want to limit
how much content you're trying
to shove at the user,
how much textual content
you're shoving at the user,
on a TV display.
You want to limit
the length of content chunks.
You know, more than a paragraph
is probably more
than they're gonna want
to read at once on TV.
And make it as big as--
as you think
it could possibly be needed,
and then you might even want
to make it a little bit bigger.
Small text sizes,
even the larger text size
example here,
is on the small side
for TV content.
It's just--I was putting
a lot of content in that design
so I needed it.
Typical onscreen font guidance,
um, still applies.
Sans-serif fonts tend
to be more readable,
and don't use a ton
of different fonts on a page
because it's kind of jarring.
On that vein, we do support
font embedding on Google TV,
which is, uh, which is handy
for Web designs.
Scrolling--
one of my favorite topics
is scrolling
because scrolling--
you don't expect
your TV to scroll.
Um, you don't expect to have
to scroll on your TV
for a Web application.
Um, in newspapers,
they have this concept
called "above the fold"
or "below the fold."
It's basically the fold
in the newspaper,
whether you--when you have
to flip it over,
that's a big deal for--
for the user,
So anything important goes
on the first page.
TV doesn't really have
a below the fold
because if it--
if it's offscreen,
I'm probably not
ever gonna see it.
I'm not gonna think
to scroll down to it.
So give visual cues to the user
if there's more content
and make it very deliberate
if you're trying to--to make
a multipage
or large canvas design.
On that same vein,
um, have a very strong
focus model.
So this is one that I also
kind of screwed up on
on a couple of the prototypes
that I was building early on.
You really want the user
to be able to see
where they are in your design
and what they can do
in your design.
My--my example of how
to mess this up
is actually one that's currently
shipping nearly everywhere,
which is DVDs.
I load a ton of DVDs.
I have a 6-year-old daughter.
She watches lots of movies.
She puts the DVD in,
and you get to that page
where it says, you know,
like, "Play," "Scene Selection,"
"Bonus Features,"
and I keep having to, like,
use the arrow keys
to figure out
where the cursor is
because the coloring
is so subtle
between the selected
and not-selected,
um, I can't tell
which one is selected.
Don't do that.
Like, make it really obvious
this one is selected
like in this design.
In that same vein,
the user is typically gonna use
the directional pad for control.
Um, they're already used
to this kind of concept
from their TV remote control,
from their DVD
or Blu-ray player
and, uh, and their gaming
console controller,
for that matter.
So thankfully, this is
really easy to support
in the Web platform.
It's just key presses.
It's arrow keys.
In fact, you saw me use
the arrow keys
in NewsGlide a few minutes ago.
This is kind of the same thing.
Um, it's actually useful
in desktop Web, as well.
Uh, Google search results
support this.
The Amazon Windowshop app
they released last fall
uses arrow key navigation.
And it actually kind of adds
a lot to the experience
if you can use arrow keys,
as well,
particularly for those of us
who like keyboard shortcuts.
The problem with this
is that the expected focus model
for TV
is two-dimensional.
Like, you expect to be able
to hit the "down" button
and go down visually
to the next focusable item.
And the Web platform
has this linear model
of "Tab" and "Shift"-"Tab."
And yes, I was around
when we invented that,
and it was a bad idea then.
It's really a bad idea
on the desktop Web, too.
You'd like to be able
to navigate through links
using the arrow keys,
and there are add-ins
to do that.
But you do have
to implement this part.
We do have some tools for that.
We'll talk about that
a little later.
And finally, um,
one of my biggest pet peeves
is the "Back" key
in Web applications.
When you're building
a Web application,
if you don't think about
what navigational model
is in your user's mind,
they're gonna find it
really disconcerting
when they go several steps
into your application,
and they've opened up
what appears to be, like,
windows inside your application
or things like that,
and they hit "Back,"
and it takes them back
to whatever Web site
they were on
before they were looking
at your Web application.
It's pretty easy to fix this.
You set the window location hash
and respond to hash
change events.
Although I will caution--
you don't want to do this
for every possible state change.
Like, that's--that's overkill.
You just want to do it
when it's a big thing
like opening up a window
in your application.
Now I want to point out
at this point
everything that I've said so far
actually applies to just TV.
It doesn't matter whether
you're using a Google TV device
or something else,
you know, Mac mini running
a different browser
attached to your TV.
It's really more when
you're displaying on a TV,
and you're using a remote
control kind of interface.
This is the one point
in this presentation
that is--that is
Google TV-specific.
We auto-zoom Web content.
So when you go to a Web site,
we're trying to make sure
that we're using
the maximum possible space.
And, um, if you want
to shut that off
in your Web application,
you can,
or if you want to control it,
you can do that through CSS,
as well.
Now on design guidance--
so these are a little bit,
like I said, they're
a little bit squishier.
They're not "you should do this"
or "this is how you do
this piece."
The first and foremost thing
is make use of every bit
of space you can on a TV display
because you are sitting
10 feet back.
You can't see things
that are really small.
Um, you'll notice,
this is YouTube on the left
and YouTube Leanback
on the right,
and the video is full screen
in YouTube Leanback.
I actually captured the controls
because I pulled them
up on screen
before I snapped the picture.
So it has all the controls,
and it has a navigation system,
but even that goes away
when you're actually just--
just watching a video.
You want to make the most use
of all the space you have.
And secondly, be sure
to actually sit back
and test your design on a TV
or preferably multiple TVs.
The reason why I say this is
it's really not enough
just to run it on a TV.
I have a TV on my desk
sitting right next
to a computer monitor
that's about the same size,
and they actually--
like, my design's gonna look
about the same
on either one of those.
The problem is when I go
and put it on my other
TV monitor and--or my other TV,
and I sit back 10 feet away,
things look very different.
You know, I can't read the text
that I wrote,
that I put up there
in 10-point font.
I might need to have it
in 24-point font.
So be sure to actually test it
in a TV situation,
not just on a TV
when you're building TV designs.
And this is a consistent thing.
When you're thinking about
the design of your application,
don't think, Well, I'm putting
this on a 1080p display,
so I've got, you know,
19 20x1080 pixels
to work with, right?
It's not quite the same
as doing that on the desktop.
Um, final bits
of--of design guidance,
kind of TV app guidance,
on TV in particular--
TV tends to be a very,
very dynamic experience,
mostly because the users of TV
are very passive.
The users of TV
are kind of like, you know,
they're couch potatoes.
They're not really paying--
uh, they're not really driving
all that much.
You want to make sure
to give them
lots of visual feedback
about what's going on
so they don't think
their computer--
or their TV experience
has stalled out.
Like, if you flip
to a TV channel
and everything's static,
you kind of say, "Well, hmm,
"TV channel's computer
must have crashed.
I'll flip to another channel."
You need to make sure
not to let your users do that.
So give visual feedback.
If you're loading something,
show a loading icon.
If something's gonna take
a few seconds, tell them that.
You probably want
to give them directions, too,
because this is kind of
a new paradigm.
They don't know to hit "Down,"
and that's what brings up
your tool bar, whatever.
So make sure to give them a
splash screen or steps to that,
or make it so that your controls
pop in very intuitively.
You hit any key,
and they--they show up.
And as I said,
uh, experiences tend
to not be static on TV.
If you flip on the news,
um, and just watch the screen,
not the person talking
but watch the screen,
elements on the screen,
most of them have, like,
dynamic backgrounds.
They have subtle animations
going on in the background,
or they have other things
that are moving underneath them
to hold the user's interest.
You probably want to replicate
that kind of effect.
Use transitions to show, uh,
to show motion
between different states.
And so now we've talked
about kind of the--the general
sets of guidance
and the practical
and technical constraints.
We want to talk
about the tools that we have
to help people build, um,
TV-optimized experiences.
The first one is if you want
to build a video content site.
So you have a-a-a pool
of video content,
and you want to get it up
and make it optimized for TV.
We have a set of TV UI templates
to do this.
These are implemented
in both HTML and Flash,
and there's
two different templates.
That's one on the left
and one on the right.
They're really
just a different view
of how you might want
to present your content.
Um, both of these
are in HTML5 and Flash.
Both of them support
directional pad navigation
and the video playback controls,
so like the "Play," "Pause,"
"Stop" buttons.
Um, and we have these
site templates up on the--
on code site,
so you can get them from there.
There's a short link to them.
But this is really only if you
want to build a top/down design,
and you can rebrand this,
of course.
That's the whole point,
is you can put whatever
branding you want in it,
use some styling to change it,
but functionally,
it'll still work the same way.
If you want to do more
than that,
or you already have a site
and you want to add
some optimization for it,
we have a set
of--a set of UI libraries
that can help you do that.
For this, I'm gonna
hand you over to Dan,
and he can talk
about what we have there.
[applause]
Lee: Great. Thank you, Chris.
So, uh, as Chris mentioned,
yeah, I'm gonna talk about
some of the Web UI libraries
that we have, uh, for
you Web developers out there
to help you with
your implementation
with developing a 10-foot user--
user interface for your TV apps.
So there's two main UI libraries
that we developed.
And, um, just to give you
a little brief history--
we launched these at the very
beginning of--of this year
around the end of January.
We had a blog post go out
on Google TV
in the beginning of February,
and there was two different
libraries that we introduced.
And the main reason--
and the main--
I think the primary goal
that we wanted to make
of--of these projects
was to really make,
uh, keyboard navigation
much, much simpler and easier
for you guys to develop
and to use.
Um, keyboard navigation
is essentially
what enables a D-pad, right,
in your app--
in your application.
As--as Chris mentioned,
with developing your--
your Web app for Google TV,
this is an extremely
critical piece
to creating
an optimal user experience,
um, with that optimal
user interaction, right?
You want your users to be able
to navigate your site,
your Web app,
using these arrow keys.
And we found that this was not
always incredibly easy to do,
especially if your UI
was a little bit more complex,
so we had two different
UI libraries
that you--that were
sort of derived
of two different
common libraries
that you guys might be
already familiar with.
One is jQuery,
and the other
is the Closure library.
I want to talk about some of
the high-level summaries that--
sort of the subtle differences
that exist between
the two libraries
to help you decide
which one to--
is a better fit for you
as a developer.
If you're already
a customer of--
if you're already a developer
of the jQuery library,
I think that's a pretty simple
choice down there for you.
The jQuery library's probably
what makes most sense
if that's what
you're already using
within your
existing applications.
Um, Closure library, if--
if you're--same reasons there.
If you're using Closure library,
that's--that's awesome,
um, and I would continue maybe
checking out
that library instead.
But let's say
you haven't used either,
and you sort of want
to evaluate between the two.
Here, I have--I'm gonna
just talk about a little bit
some of the differences.
And jQuery library requires
a little bit more JavaScript.
So it's a little bit more
heavier on the JavaScript side,
so it's gonna do a lot more,
where you're gonna be sort of
configuring your library
using JavaScript
a little bit more
whereas the Closure library,
you're sort of doing more
within your HTML markup.
So you're essentially decorating
common HTML elements
like--like DIV containers
or unordered list containers
or span elements and so forth
and just decorating them
with special class names
that the library
will then parse through
and essentially, you know, do--
apply some logic to that
and include that within
your keyboard navigation.
The jQuery library,
instead, you'll be using things
like CSS selector strings,
which if you're already
using jQuery
you might be familiar with.
And one additional thing
that it--it provides
is we offer--which is currently
in beta, by the way--
is a set of common UI controls,
things like horizontal carousels
like--like slider controls
or the embedding of--of photos,
doing, like, a slide show,
or embedding videos.
It includes some library--some
additional libraries like that,
which are part
of the jQuery UI library,
and it integrates
keyboard navigation within that.
So--so those are some
additional UI controls
that the jQuery UI library
offers
which the Closure library
doesn't.
On the other hand,
the Closure UI library,
however, offers you, um,
you know, really, really raw
building blocks to build
a really customized and really
complex user interface.
So it--it contains, you know,
your building blocks
as with like horizontal
and vertical containers,
with scrollable components
within,
but it also contains extensions
of those components
such as buttons.
Um, you can sort of create
links, you know,
where it immediately can
navigate to a different URL
if--if the "Enter" key
gets pressed,
and they can listen for that.
Um, it has menu controls,
as well.
So these are--these--
and I'll show you some examples
of this later on,
but those are some
of the subtle differences,
I'd say, between the two.
So the Closure library's
a little bit more sort of
starting from the ground up,
where the jQuery, I think,
provides you with a little bit--
it tries to do
a little bit more for you.
There's three main--
three main steps,
uh, in getting started on
using these--these libraries
if you want to use them,
and really--they're
really highlighted here,
and there's stuff that if you're
a Web developer out there,
this is stuff that you're
probably already familiar with.
Um, but really, it's these
simple three steps
where you're using HTML markup
to define the structure
of--of your UI.
So you are gonna specify,
you know, using HTML,
you know, which component,
what are your components
that you want selectable
with the cursor, you know,
and then how do you--
do you want them
to be selectable horizontally,
using left and right keys,
versus up/down.
Second is CSS.
You're gonna be using CSS3
because you know
you're developing
your Web app on Chrome,
and that's a huge benefit,
as Chris mentioned,
because you're only dealing
with one browser here.
You know what HTML5 capabilities
are available.
You know what WebKit transitions
and transforms you can use.
And so you're gonna
really be using CSS a lot
to present and help you
sort of visualize--
apply visualization to these--
these, you know,
these--these HTML components
that you're adding
within your Web app.
And then lastly,
you're using JavaScript
to really initialize--
it's really used to initialize
the library,
initialize the keyboard
navigation to be active,
to essentially parse through
your HTML DOM, for example,
and look for those
special class names
or select all the, you know,
all of the nodes that match
the CSS selective strings
and then to--and then
to make them keyboard navigable.
So here's--here's, uh,
the next, you know, few set
of slides, I want to--
I want to go over a little bit
more in depth, right,
like the different steps in
terms of using each library.
So I want to start with jQuery,
and this is a little bit of a,
you know, a visual diagram
of--of what may be--
what the zone--
you know, what--how you would
sort of lay out your structure.
Let's say you wanted to use
the slider, right?
So there's a concept of--
of keyboard behavior zones,
and these zones are essentially
nothing more
than HTML containers,
so I typically use these
with developments
or a UL, unordered list element.
And then, you know,
within each zone,
you can contain a list
of a variety of different
HTML components,
which can--which are, again,
are just HTML elements
that you're already
familiar with.
They can be image tags.
They can be paragraph tags.
You can do whatever you want.
And you're essentially
gonna identify--
you're gonna create some way
to indentify those components
within each zone.
And each zone
is essentially--
um, you know, can be scrolled--
it can be selected, you know,
left or right,
depending on whether or not
you want them to be selected
horizontally or vertically.
Um, and so in
your jQuery library,
you're essentially
in your HTML structure
going to be setting up,
you know, different--
different zones with different
selectable components within.
One added benefit
that the jQuery library
takes care of for you
is that when you're navigating
up and down between zones,
it's automatically gonna
remember the last selected item
within each zone,
so that's something
that's convenient
that the library
takes care of for you.
The last optional feature,
which I want to just mention,
is really great for,
uh, quick prototyping.
So let's say you have already
an existing Web site
or a Web app
that you want to see what it--
you know, you want
to quickly enable
keyboard navigation
on your Web app.
The jQuery UI library provides
something called
a Geometry feature.
So you can toggle this flag
called useGeometry
and set it to true,
and when it does that,
it'll sort of--
you know, based on, you know,
an Euclidean--
it uses an Euclidean
distance algorithm,
and it tries to calculate,
What's the next closest item
to the right, top, bottom,
or left of this item
that I'm currently at?
And so when the user
hits "Right,"
it'll try its best to select
the next most intuitive element
that it should go to.
Like I said, this is great
for prototyping.
I don't--I wouldn't recommend
leaving it turned on
if you're going
to full production
because there's,
you know, visual--
potentially maybe
some visual differences
maybe that you're just sort of
less in control over
exactly where the focus
is gonna move to next.
So, uh, it's great
for prototyping,
um, but not meant
for full production.
Here's an example of, uh,
of the HTML structure that you--
that--one example
of what it might look like.
Let's say you wanted to build
some interface.
Um, here's a concept.
This is just HTML markup here,
so you're essentially
creating two zones--
I'm essentially
creating two zones here,
a zone one and a zone two.
Within the zone,
I'm defining a set of rows.
I can have one, two,
as many item rows
as--as poss--as I want.
And I'm setting a class--
a special class name
called "item-row,"
which I'm gonna be using
CSS selective strings
to tell the jQuery UI library
"Here are my rows."
And my rows are navigable
horizontally from left to right.
Within each row, I'm embedding
individual components
that I'm also identifying
using semantic class names,
so I'm calling it
a class "item,"
and I'm saying for those items,
I want those
to be focusable, right?
So--so you can imagine,
with this sort of a structure,
you can really--
depending on, you know, how--
the sizing you would
control using CSS,
you know, your width and height
rules and so forth.
Um, but you can really do
a lot of nesting
to create a variety
of different rows
and then different components--
selectable components within.
I wanted to just,
again, mention,
you know, that CSS
is incredibly important
in terms of laying out your--
your HTML
and--and presenting them
to the user
to help visualize how you want
your items to be navigable.
So, for example,
if you can read some
of the CSS rules here--
you don't have to look through
all of them--
but, you know, I'm applying
everything from some margins
to, you know, some dimensions,
width and height,
and also border radiuses
and so forth.
Last--the last step
which I mentioned--
you know, there was three steps,
and JavaScript is--is what
you're gonna be using
to initialize
keyboard navigation
for, uh, your HTML markup,
which has already been set up
in the way I just showed you.
And so this is an example.
This is just a code snippet
of how you would essentially
create new instances
of a key behavior zone object.
Within the key behavior
zone object,
contains a variety
of different object parameters
that you're gonna use to
configure and tell the library
how to identify which components
are selectable,
which components are rows
and so forth.
Some things I want
to highlight here
is the CSS selective strings,
right?
So I'm telling the library
for every--every--
every, uh, every HTML element
that has a class name item,
I want that to be selectable.
Um, I'm going to tell it,
you know, every--every--
every class name that
has a specified item-row,
that's gonna be represented
as a row.
The selection class's property
is--is what you're gonna be
using to tell the library,
you know, when--when my user
is actually focused
on a specific element,
it's going to apply--
essentially append
this specific class name
to that element.
So in my CSS, I can then give it
some special styling
to make it very apparent
to the user
where my current focus is.
And lastly, the last example,
is key mapping.
There's a key mapping property
where you can specify a variety
of different key codes.
So these key codes are available
on the Web, right?
And--and 13 is the key code
that register--
that fires when the user
hits the "Enter" key.
And I'm telling
jQuery library here
to call my "Enter"
callback function,
which I have to find
somewhere else,
to handle that--that event
when it gets fired.
And at the bottom there--
the bottom box essentially
just shows how you--
how it essentially ties
everything together.
So we have a-a top level--
a key controller object,
which you're creating
a new instance of,
and then you're creating--
you're adding the two behavior
zones that I created to it,
and then you're calling
a start method
with the very first zone
that you want
to start the selection on.
So that's--that's essentially
a very, very quick
and dumb-downed
sort of code snippet
and how easy it is to enable
keyboard navigation
on your Web app.
I want to go through
the same set of steps now
with the--with the exception
of now we're talking
about Closure library,
because--just to show you
a little bit subtle differences
between the two.
And this is sort of
the conceptual model
of how the Closure UI library
works instead.
So we had the concept
of horizontal and vertical
building blocks.
So these are, again,
nothing but HTML containers.
And one of the key differences
between the jQuery
and the Closure
is that the jQuery library,
like I said,
you're--you're specifying
in your--in your constructor,
you know, which--which objects,
which HTML elements
I want to include
using CSS selective strings.
But in the Closure UI library,
you're essentially doing this
directly within your markup.
So in your--in your HTML markup,
you're--you're specifying
class names,
these special class names,
that all start out
with a "tv-" prefix.
So things like
"tv-container-horizontal"
will indicate to the library
that I want this container
to be scrollable--
to be navigable left--
using left and right keys.
It also contains--
we also have special class names
to identify
which containers
can be scrollable.
And so within your CSS,
if you specify
like a smaller viewport window,
so a small width
and a small height
that only shows, let's say,
three components inside,
you can specify that
to be a scrolling container
very easily,
similarly by applying
a class name.
And then I briefly talked
about how there's different
extensions of TV components,
which are--are all
gonna be selectable
with your keyboard navigation,
and this could include things
like buttons and links
and also input, for example.
So what does the HTML markup
look like
for this library instead?
So this is
a very similar example.
Uh, I have essentially
two snippets
of, uh, a UL element
with class name--
the special class names
"tv-container-horizontal"
and "tv-container-vertical."
And that's essentially saying
to the library
"I want this container
"to be navigable
using left/right keys
"and then the other one
to be navigable
using up and down arrow keys."
Within my--my horizontal
and vertical containers,
I have three
different components,
which I'm specifying
as a TV component,
and that's telling the library
that I want this
to be selectable.
If I had additional elements
in there
that were not labeled
with that class,
then the library
wouldn't recognize it
and include it in that container
as they're navigating
with their keyboard.
And then the last thing
on the right,
I show you, again, some examples
of the CSS styling rules
that is really critical
to helping to visualize,
uh, or represents these--
these HT--this markup
and make it look sort of
the way you want it to navigate.
So for example, for--for
all list elements
within my horizontal container,
I want to apply a display--
an inline block display rule,
which is gonna stack them,
you know--
instead of stacking them
one below each other,
I'm gonna put them
next to each other instead.
On this slide, I wanted
to also show
that as an example, uh,
TV container--like, horizontal
and vertical containers
are not, uh, do not have to be
stand-alone on themselves.
You can actually use them
to nest within each other,
um, and this is actually part
of how you would actually build
a complex UI with this.
'Cause you can imagine you have
a variety of different--
maybe you have one top-level
vertical container
that you want to be able
to create, essentially,
different zones almost,
similar to what--what
I showed you with jQuery,
and create a variety
of different rows, um,
that you're creating
using the horizontal containers.
The next point I wanted
to talk about
is I mentioned
scrolling containers.
So if I have, uh, a list of--
a long list of elements,
TV components within
a scrolling container,
such as--like, that's going
vertically in this example,
and let's say I use CSS
to minimize the viewport
of my vertical container
to only show three components
at a time.
I can essentially just wrap
all my child components
around a special, uh, class name
called
"tv-container-start-scroll,"
and as I'm scrolling down,
the library
will magically enable this
so that if--as the user
heads down on the arrow keys,
it's going to always maintain--
it's gonna--it's--
it's gonna scroll--
the vertical container's
gonna translate it
using WebKit transforms
to move down to--to show
the next, you know,
the next component that--
that's below it.
And so it just kind of
works magically,
and it really--
it really is up to you
to use, uh, CSS rules
to--to enable the interaction
to appear this way.
And lastly, JavaScript is--
this is the last piece
of JavaScript
that you're really gonna be
using to enable this library
to sort of initialize
and scan through your HTML DOM
and look for these
special class names
and then include it within
your keyboard navigation scheme.
So essentially,
what I'm showing here--
there's a single method
that you're gonna be calling
called "tv.ui.decorate,"
and within that, you're passing
in the route parent HTML node
where it's then gonna
scan through
all of his child elements
and look for these--
these specially decorated
class names.
And then at the bottom there,
you're essentially
just calling "tryFocus"
on the first element
that you want to start out
your focus on.
So I want to just show
really quick
a few demos, uh,
of essentially
very similar interfaces,
but I wanted to show
some building blocks
that are using both the Closure
library and the jQuery.
I think visually,
they're--they're not
going to necessarily appear
very different,
but they're both--
it just goes to show
that you can really accomplish
the same--
very similar interfaces
with both libraries,
that it's really
a matter of taste
and depending on
what it is you want to do.
Am I, uh, connected?
Wilson: [speaking indistinctly]
Lee: I could have had this...
Lee: Could be I lost
our internet connection.
Hmm.
I'm gonna try this again.
Mm...
Are you on Wi-Fi?
Let me try this.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Lee: [laughs]
That's a good request.
Uh, I'll have karaoke
for you afterwards
in the Sandbox area.
[laughs]
I'll take requests, too.
[chuckles]
Wilson: All right.
Lee: Okay, um,
so unfortunately,
we're having some Wi-Fi--
or--or...
Wilson: Wired.
Lee: Wired
internet connection issues.
Um, if you go to that--
that go link, um,
you can actually check out
some of the demos yourself.
And all of--you can navigate
the entire demo site
using, uh, using keyboard,
and that's the whole point,
right?
And so it's actually
a really good--good exercise
for you to check out
those demos,
look at
the various examples within,
and then look at the--
view the source,
and you'll see how simple
the HTML markup actually looks,
um, and then you'll see
the JavaScript library--
the calling functions
which I showed you here.
So, uh, so, thank you,
and then I guess
I'll give it back to Chris.
Wilson: Thanks, Dan.
[applause]
Wilson: So--thanks.
So really, what we're asking
people to do is to think about
how the applications you're
already building might work
in the TV space
in the living room.
Think about what
new applications
actually you could build
because you're in that space.
And also, I personally believe
there are a lot of lessons
we can learn
about how to build
better experiences
that work on desktop and mobile
and are more effective
in those spaces, as well,
once you look at how that works
when you're kind of
kicking back.
And finally, you know,
get a Google TV device,
start building applications.
Um, if you have applications
you want to build
and you need a device,
get ahold of us.
We can--I'm sure we can work
something out.
We have a code site.
We have a forum that we
participate in quite a bit.
And with that, we're actually,
um, just about out of time,
so, uh, uh, I do want to ask
that anyone who can
please provide feedback
on the session.
That helps us get better.
And, um, our hash tags
are up there.
So if you have questions,
come on up, ask them to us,
but I think we're gonna have
to hand over the stage
to the next--next set.
[applause]